whether you are a fan from way back or
just got into the series when it was
added to hbo max
the big bang theory remains one of the
most binge-worthy sitcoms in recent
memory with a story that runs 12 seasons
and 279 episodes the series makes for
many hours of enjoyment
as well as plenty of opportunities to
spot potential plot holes and continuity
errors
that's to be expected with any
long-running series though
and spotting gaps in logic or very
specific errors
can even add an extra level of enjoyment
to a re-watch
fans of the big bang theory certainly
seem to think so as they often take to
reddit to share the plot holes they
uncover deep
in the show's history unraveling how
these mess-ups affect the rest of the
series
then also adds to the fun of seeking
them out
one error recently uncovered by
eagle-wide redditors carries big
implications for the backstory of
sheldon cooper not only on the big bang
theory but also the prequel series
young sheldon there's an issue with
sheldon's age and it isn't that the show
hasn't told us when he was born
rather the problem is that the show
tells us when sheldon was born
but later contradicts that date it was
referenced multiple times that sheldon
and his twin sister missy were born on
february 26
1980. however as reddit user dgn act
discovered
the map of sheldon's various life
accomplishments doesn't quite add up
if one examined sheldon's own accounting
of his past in the first season episode
the luminous fish effect
after he gets fired from his job shona
declares he's not interested in getting
it back
saying i've spent the past three and a
half years staring at grease boards full
of equations
before that i spent four years working
on my thesis before that i was in
college and before that
i was in the fifth grade now another
established fact is that
sheldon being the difficult genius he is
started college when he was 11 years old
a major plot point in young sheldon
however dg anak notes that when that
timeline is added up
four years for college four for his phd
thesis
and three and a half working before the
beginning of the series
that puts his age in the luminous fish
effect at only 22.
that's about five years shy of how old
he should be at that point which is 27.
this timeline fumble is likely nothing
more than the result of a mistake in the
script but it's also not the first time
the show has had trouble pinning down
exactly when sheldon was born the show
also goofed on sheldon's astrological
sign
whether or not you believe that
someone's astrological sign has any
correlation to their personality
western astrology does work off of a
specific set of dates to categorize
people
into one of 12 specific signs however in
the case of the big bang theory the
lines between someone's actual birthday
and their sign occasionally gets blurred
for example in the season 1 episode the
peanut reaction
penny is talking with sheldon and
leonard about the group's various zodiac
signs
she says i was going to do everybody's
until sheldon went on one of his typical
psychotic rants
after sheldon repeats his rant against
the legitimacy of astrology penny
responds
blah blah blah typical taurus it's a
funny line but shawn's february 26th
birthday makes him a pisces
not a taurus penny herself even confirms
this fact in the season 8 episode
the intimacy acceleration after learning
that at sheldon's birthday she responds
that was so funny i never would have
pegged you for a pisces
this might all seem like it's fixating
extra hard on sheldon's birthday
so to switch things up have a look at
the time the show couldn't decide where
sheldon was born
instead of win sheldon's mother mary
cooper became one of the big bang
theory's best love supporting characters
because of her texas-sized personality
and the fact that she and sheldon
are comically different people one of
the first things that viewers learn
about mary
is that she gave birth to sheldon in a
rather unconventional
location this occurs in the episode the
luminous fish effect
wherein mary comes to town to try and
shake sheldon out of the depressive
episode he falls into
after losing his job while talking to
his friends about her son mary says
i'll tell you i love the boy to death
but he has been difficult since he fell
out of me at the kmart
just one season later though viewers
were already given an alternative
location for sheldon's birth
in the season 2 episode the lizard spock
expansion
sheldon asserts that he was born at the
fictional lawrence memorial hospital
not at a department store so after all
that
here's the lowdown on seanan's birth he
was born on february 26th
and sometime in april between the years
1980 through 1985
at the kmart inside the lawrence
memorial hospital glad that's all
cleared up
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one